2050 il y aura sur la terre 10 milliards
d'humains
comment les nourrir pour que non
seulement eux soit en santé mais la
planète aussi en réduisant l'impact de
l'agriculture
cela fait trois ans que des experts de
16 pays planchent sur la question et le
régime alimentaire planétaire
c'est la revue britannique de 27 qui le
publie le nombre de calories d'abord
2500 par jour dans les pays riches c'est
plutôt 3700 aujourd'hui et que mettre
dans notre assiette remplir à moitié de
fruits et de légumes 500 grammes par
jour avec des céréales complètes et des
noix et légumineuses pour les protéines
les protéines animales
elle ne doit pas disparaître avec un
accent mis sur la volaille et le poisson
les 14 grammes de boeuf quotidiens
recommandés
c'est l'équivalent d'un petit steaks par
semaine quant au sucre ajouté pas plus
de 11 grammes par jour bref il faut
réduire de moitié pour l'amérique du
nord ce nouveau menu demande un
changement assez radical la ligne en
pointillés sur ce graphique c'est la
portion idéal on le voit boeuf féculents
oeuf volailles et les il y en a trop
c'est il faut bien plus de noix de
grains complets et de légumineuses les
experts sont optimistes sans être naïf
oui c'est possible de préserver santé et
planète
mais est-ce probable là il ne se
prononce pas ici mathieu prost radio
canada montréal